do you remember that the first time like
the first time we got paid for doing
comedy oh wow it took it took a long
time to get there but yeah the first
time was uh and I got paid to do an
event I think it was in like Virginia
and it was right after I did Last Comic
Standing and whoever hired me had gotten
fired and the person in now in charge
was kind of like ah okay we'll figure
this out I got to this venue and the
stage was a crate just a milk crate that
you stand on the light was one of those
construction clamps
and the the sound the sound was a a very
cheap karaoke machine and I was like oh
this is not gonna go well and my opener
was supposed to do 20 minutes he lasted
two minutes because we had this venue
that it was in a biker bar it was in a
biker bar that's not where I was hired
to perform and these bikers were just
looking at me going no no thank you oh
my God yeah I thought it was gonna be
like you won them over and suddenly you
were like dancing in tandem with the
bikers I wish they were just like
whatever you're talking about we don't
want oh my God I had to be up there for
45 minutes because the other clown left
yeah yeah so like I I think I lasted
like 30 in the last 15 I was like who
wants a q a
they were like we don't know you
our question is who are you
oh my god well it builds our character
it does times yeah my mom came with me
to that gig I was like first paid gig
and she was like oh do you so she's like
so this is yeah are you sure this is it
hey if you lasted there and you made it
through that I mean here we are 12 years
later I think I'm I'm finally getting
the hang of it oh my God it is funny
though all of our like first jobs like
did you get painted in it they're crazy
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]